Speaker 1: So over the weekend, I got together
with a friend of mine who hosts another show
like this one, I don't want to say who it
is because, you know, they they may not want
their their view to be particularly public.
But one of the things we talked about is how
lately we are hearing these defenses of authoritarians
from the people on the right that we would
expect to hear them from.
But the contingent of the left, which we used
to call the authoritarian left, and I guess
we still do, but it used to be way smaller.
The portion of the left that is sort of playing
coy with and often defending authoritarian
strongman types is growing to the point that
it is a really major concern, I think, for
those who are really on the sort of libertarian
progressive left and that small L libertarian
as in not authoritarian not I'm not talking
Rand Paul libertarianism.
I'm talking between on the authoritarian libertarian
scale.
You're on the libertarian progressive left,
and there's now increasingly sort of a rift
within the left.
And one of the things I spoke about with my
friend and fellow host was that sometimes
it occurs to us that it would be really great
to do some kind of an expose about like what?
Why are we seeing this linkage, this cozy
relationship between the right authoritarian
sort of populist rhetoric people and some
on the left who seem to support the exact
same authoritarians in this sometimes is Assad
a sometimes it's Nicolas Maduro, sometimes
it's Putin, sometimes it's playing coy with
China.
And there are certainly other examples.
And fundamentally, what I think this is about
and if you want examples of this, just look
at it.
Tucker Carlson, program one or two nights
a week and see who Tucker is having on from
the supposed left where they find common ground.
And we're supposed to believe they are crossing
partizan lines in order to find areas of agreement.
That just makes sense when the reality is
that the authoritarian left has always had
plenty in common with the right.
It's not that they're escaping partizan partizanship
to come together where it makes obvious sense
on uncontroversial issues.
It's actually that the authoritarian aspect
of some on the left really is not very left.
It's really quite right wing that that's the
reality of what's going on.
And along these lines, Fox News ran a bizarre,
glowing profile of Vladimir Putin in ahead
of Joe Biden's meeting with Putin.
And fundamentally, what this is about for
both the right and the left is that for different
reasons, they want to delegitimize the idea
that somebody on the left, meaning a Democrat,
is going to hold such an authoritarian accountable,
because for those on the right, it's about
we just never want to allow any Democrat to
appear strong going back to John Kerry.
And even before it's about the feminization
of Democrats, it's about the these are not
strong people.
These are sissies, et cetera.
That's that's why Fox News would want to sort
of portray Putin as masculine and and a glowing
profile advance of meeting with Biden so that
they don't want to make Biden look bad.
And for the left, it's this stuff of any time
the United States even stands up to anyone
that's neo liberalism, that's hegemonic, that's
colonialism, etc..
And so, hey, the right and these aspects of
the left end up wanting to similarly raise
up people like Vladimir Putin.
I will never get it.
But let's take a look at some of this glowing
profile.
It's it's almost North Korea esque in some
way of Vladimir Putin on Fox News and
Speaker 2: the overwhelming support you'd
have to look to the man who came before him.
And the drunken antics seemed the exact opposite
of Vladimir Putin.
Just the Steve Harrigan lived in Russia for
ten years.
And he's got more on this now.
Boris Yeltsin, Vladimir Putin study in contrasts,
right?
Sharp contrast, John, especially at the very
start when Putin came in in nineteen ninety
nine, his approval ratings for an unknown
were overwhelmingly high.
And part of the reason was just the physical
contrast he made with Boris Yeltsin.
By nineteen ninety nine, most Russians were
ready for a change, the hero who stood on
the tank in nineteen ninety one and broke
communist control over freedom of speech,
elections and private property was also blamed
by those who saw their life savings disappear
as a new class of billionaires scooped up
state factories, Yeltsin's lengthy disappearances
from public view were blamed on heart attacks
or excessive drinking.
Speaker 3: To many Russians, President Boris
Yeltsin felt like an embarrassment.
This is very famous for
Speaker 1: so this is all the buildup to get
to the great Putin, right?
This is all about the bad stuff about Yeltsin
versus being inbreed.
Speaker 3: It was a nonalcoholic and a big
drinker.
He was very large just in stature.
So the way that he behaved in these kind of
level, public diplomacy, meetings with US
presidents, other heads of state embarrassed
a lot of Russians at the time.
Speaker 2: The physical contrast with Putin
was stark.
Speaker 1: And if you're watching, if you're
not watching, they're running video of Putin
lifting weights and then it gets even more
sycophantic.
Speaker 3: Say he's a martial arts champion
in karate, says he never drinks.
And for many Russians now also gave them a
sense of stability.
Mr. Putin embodied that physically in a way
that President Yeltsin absolutely did not.
Speaker 2: Putin also embodied a return to
an authoritarian past, shutting down press
freedom, vanishing independent oligarchs and
consolidating power in his own hands.
Putin could be around for a long time to come.
He's changed the Constitution.
He could potentially be in office until the
year 2036, John.
He knows how to consolidate power.
No question about that.
Steve Harrigan, Foresty, thank you so much.
And and can you imagine Sandra Boris Yeltsin
on horseback without a shirt on?
That's not a pretty picture.
Speaker 1: Yeah, so there it is.
And so fundamentally, what would I think is
going on here?
There are more and more people that are actually
calling out not just the right, but also those
on the left who are playing coy with these
guys.
I think there's a couple of important things
to to to sort of keep in mind here.
Number one is that there is no circumstance
in which progressive values align with the
way that Vladimir Putin runs government.
Bashar al-Assad, Nicolas Maduro.
Sometimes there will be people on the left
even even defending Hamas.
It's often the exact same people there that
there's nothing progressive about that.
And it's really important to to bear that
in mind.
But one of the really toxic things that's
going on with the left on this issue is when
someone like me, for example, calls this out,
I will be called everything from a Zionist,
even though this doesn't directly relate.
Putin doesn't directly relate to the Israeli-Palestinian
conflict, although some of those people are
also playing pretty coy with Hamas to a neoliberal
colonialist, to a faux progressive, to a right
winger, et cetera, et cetera.
But what I would challenge those folks to
look at is if you look at the history of social
democracy around the world and in Northern
Europe, cetera, when has progressive social
democracy ever looked like people like Vladimir
Putin and Assad and she and Maduro, et cetera?
And so the case I would make is that this
sort of authoritarian left that plays coy
with this stuff that Fox News does on Putin
and others, they are the ones that have been
either led astray or for whatever personal
reasons, have decided that that's the direction
they want to go in.
The progressive social democracy movement
looks quite similar today to what it did decades
and decades ago.
And unfortunately, with a lot of these examples,
if you follow the money, you start to learn
a lot about why some of these factions are
staking out the positions that they're staking
out and maybe will say more about
that
in
the future.